the new Congress will be sworn in
tomorrow Republicans will have a larger
majority in the Senate while Democrats
will control the house for the first
time in eight years
New York Congressman Jerry now they will
become chairman of the Judiciary
Committee which has the power to
subpoena witnesses and documents to
investigate President Trump and his
administration congressman Nadler good
morning and Happy New Year thank you
Happy New Year so we know that we are
now in day 12 of the shutdown what's the
plan that the Democrats are going to
present to the president well you know
the budget of the United States consists
of twelve bills
five of which have been passed into law
the there's six more that are totally
agreed upon that the Senate passed
almost unanimously so our plan is to
pass those six bills to send it back to
the Senate and pass for the one
remaining Department Department of
Homeland Security pass a continuing
resolution to fund it through February a
so there can be more negotiations but
this shutdown that President Trump is
initiated proudly he claimed it is
really blackmail of the American people
because he is feeling abandoned he's
been abandoned first by the voters the
historical nine million majority for
Democratic candidates for Congress a
couple months ago he's being abandoned
by his own Secretary of Defense by his
chief of staff by all by his former
campaign manager party he didn't control
the Republicans did control the house in
the last but let's talk about these are
people who have left him work who are
testifying against him and whenever he
feels beleaguered he returns to his base
so what this shutdown is really is an
extremist policy designed to appeal to
an extremist base and hold the whole
country hostage if you can separate
those bills have the Department of
Homeland Security one which will include
the fight over the course the border
wall funding do you think that the
president will sign that in this
shutdown could be over for all those
other agencies by Thursday well he
certainly should he has said unless they
or so or I think he spokesman who said
they wouldn't but remember the Senate
the Republican Senate passed those six
bills unanimously or almost unanimously
a few weeks ago we'll take the Senate
bill we'll pass it again and hopefully
they'll pass it and the president should
sign it unless he simply wants to
deliberately create an artificial
shutdown of a
part of the government in which this
world business controversy has nothing
to do with just in order to blackmail
the American piece is there anybody on
the Democrat side on a border wall not
really at this point that suggests there
might be in another point I don't know
that the fact of the matter is the
border wall is a purposeless thing we're
certainly willing to talk about border
security and the fact of the matter is
that of course that people crossing the
border are way down this year and last
year than in previous years the
challenge we have is not people crossing
the border that way it's people who want
political asylum and a wall can't help
that because they want to walk up and
present themselves to the first agents
and say I want political asylum so the
wall has nothing to do with the problem
that we have you've had a second child
died at the border
it certainly is escalated the blame game
how do you fix that because that is
really the crux to the problem here
these two sides not being able to sit
down with one it's not a question of the
two sides not being disabled to sit down
it's a question of inhuman policies
being followed by the Trump
administration to try to as was said by
several of their spokespeople including
former chief of staff Kelly to deter
people from coming to the board and
claiming political asylum based on
violence or whatever in order to do that
will make them as miserable as possible
and unfortunately that means that kids
die and we're certainly going to have
hearings in the Judiciary Committee and
subpoena witnesses and documents if
necessary they're all relevant documents
as to why kids are dying in custody of
DHS why families are being detained what
about the policy of family separation
you still have kids who haven't been
returned to their parents after months
this is inhuman and it's not precedented
it's a deliberate creation of the Trump
administration which is trying to make
things as miserable as possible and if
kids die they're apparently willing to
have that do you you have a long and
very contentious history with this
president he once called you one of the
most egregious hacks and contemporary
politics I regard that as a badge of
honor you are about to take over the
district committee and you've said that
impeachment
hearings are something that you only
resort to in the most extreme
circumstances in your view what are
those circumstances well impeachment is
designed as a defense of the Republic
against a president who would aggregate
ice power destroy Liberty destroy
democratic institutions destroy the
separation of powers if that happens if
you get real evidence of that then you
then you have to consider impeachment
hearings but we will wait and see what
and there's certainly a lot of
allegations but we'll have to wait and
see what what the mo investigation comes
up with another and other other
investigations looking into it but we're
also going to be for the last two years
the president has had no oversight and
no accountability from Congress the
Republican Congress was completely
derelict in its responsibility to
provide oversight we are going to
provide that oversight we're gonna use
the subpoena power if we have to we will
call in mr. Whitacre for instance we'll
have to protect the mo investigation and
pass that legislation we're calling mr.
Whitacre who's agreed to come in
although he can't seem to find a date I
will subpoena him if necessary and we'll
ask questions about is that job one for
you and when you take over the committee
well it's it's one of two jobs first
jobs to pass HR 1 which is the
democratization bill to guarantee for
free elections deal with gerrymandering
deal with campaign finance so people
can't buy the alot by elections so
people feel that the elections are
proper alright on that they control them
not not plutocrats we've got to go car
but thank you Jerry now thanks so much
for being with us as we welcome